Hello and welcome to Metahuman DNA Calibration and Finalization.
My name is Gabriela Cresenio-Tacas and I will be your host for this course.
This course is a continuation of the Metahuman Fitting and DNA Calibration course.
We will delve into more advanced use case scenarios for using the DNA Calibration library
to modify the Metahuman Neutral Pose and explore workflows for integrating it with
a custom Metahuman body.
We will also dive into best practices for finalizing Metahuman customizations in Unreal Engine.
It is worth mentioning that with newer engine versions some of these workflows have changed
and we will explore the new workflows in a future update.
Now let's take a look at what we will be covering in this course.
We will get started by touching upon advanced use cases where DNA calibration has been
used to make changes to the Metahuman head and body.
One case is the 2023 Unreal Fest DNA Calibration deep dive and the other is how the stylized
character Atomic Savage was customized with multiple workflows using DNA calibration.
We will then look at all of the steps that were taken to customize Atomic Savage from
the initial concept to the finalized rig.
From there I will break down some of the workflows in greater detail and walk you through how
you might apply these workflows to your own characters.
The first workflow we will delve into includes a modified version of the Unreal Fest Calibration
script.
We will go over how to edit the Metahuman Neutral Pose by transferring the details from the
fitted head geometry assets that we looked at in the previous course to a Metahuman
identity and then save those changes to the Metahuman DNA file.
For the second workflow we will go over how we can merge the modified Metahuman Neutral
Pose with a custom Metahuman body for seamless integration.
From there we will go through all of the steps for bringing the customized assets back into
Unreal Engine with a hands-on exercise.
We will go over how to re-import the head-LOD-FBX files, update the Metahuman DNA file and the
Metahuman Blueprint, and then we will look at how to import and assign a custom Metahuman
body skeletal mesh.
We will then wrap up this course with some final recommendations and I will share some
tips and resources for you to use as you continue your training with Metahumans.
This course will be using the project MEH9130055 and the level map should load automatically.
The map is located in the content browser under the courses folder labeled MEH31301.
In the course maps folder and it is named MEH31301MAPEX for example.
This map contains the non-modified version of the atomic savage character and we will
be using this map to configure all of the customizations we will be bringing into the
engine for the hands-on portion of our course.
If you want to inspect the fully assembled version of this character, that is located
under the course folder named MEH21302 in the course maps folder and it is named MEH21302MAPC
for customized.
Now all of the scripts and assets we will be using throughout this course are located
in the source files folder of our course named 31301DNACalibAssets.
Inside of that folder you will find two scripts and their associated assets and in the folder
named POSEDRIVERCONNECT you will find the RBF solvers that we will bring into the engine
later on.
If you need to reference the location of the course map that can be found at the beginning
of the slide deck after the training outline.
Now as we go through this course you will find that many slides in this presentation
contain a lot of information and I will summarize all of that for you but if at any point you
want to read what is on each of those slides feel free to pause and dive right in.
Now let's get started with the first portion of this course where we look at some advanced
use case scenarios for making changes to the metahuman face and body using the DNA calibration
library.